what's happening there reject nation
greg and aaron back at it to watch
umbrella academy episode three of season
three last episode was pretty gosh darn
good i hear this season only gets better
as it goes guys leave a like that would
be very much appreciated your thoughts
down below what you think of season
three also subscribe click that
notification bell get notified when our
reaction for the next episode of
umbrella academy is up aaron how are you
doing i forgot to ask i'm wonderful baby
getting used to the mics getting used to
the mics it's weird but you know what i
had a full day of work today and i'm uh
socially lubed
i love it i love that
uh guys full length reaction watch looks
for you sync up with the time code using
your own copy of umbrella academy over
at our patreon page become a super sexy
reject by checking out everything else
we got to offer over there as well got a
bunch lastly them boys at prepper thank
you for helping us edit down these
highlights let's get to it
it's new jersey
1953 and elmer tatelman hates his
grandfather join the club
now i love my grandpa how many times do
i have to tell you no god damn peace you
don't like what i cook you can make it
yourself
oh jesus elmer is about to invent
[Music]
time travel
oh
key to his future happiness is to go
back in time
and kill his grant
that's me
you're gonna kill yourself dummy
but he's made one crucial mistake he
went too far back in time murdering his
grandfather in 1905 meant that elmer's
mother didn't exist to meet his father
in 1925
mm-hmm yeah but if elmer no longer
exists how could he possibly kill his
grandfather elmer has created a paradox
the grandfather paradox
so we're dealing with a paradox
a grandfather paradox
certain nothing like this ever happens
except you didn't because that's why
season three is here
help us out
that's an umbrella
one cool before someone sees you
he hasn't been laid in a while
so what happens when you pine after your
sister hell yeah
[Music]
that's right remember when he was such a
stiff in season one yup just a big old
stiffy two bucks
[Music]
oh and you know what to do
smooth
some of those
please get the small one for six
and i will have some doritos no no the
other ones
well [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh this guy's gone jack the condoms
personally i'd go for the pencils right
there yeah
i never used too many pencils
oh damn it let's go take more pencils
yeah stanley now is not the time to be
doing karate okay yeah well mom said i
need to practice yeah well she's not
wrong you're very bad
aren't you retired i want nothing more
you know you can't keep dragging us
through hell because you have an itch
only an apocalypse can scratch and then
expect us to deal with the fallout
you're not the boss i'm going to just
stop rejecting your daughter issues on
us don't leave five don't leave no klaus
i'm leaving he has a pretty good track
record with this stuff i feel like we
should listen to him sure hey
quick question
netflix cross promotion we need to find
out who did this this is the thing this
is the main thing is that all you want
yeah cause it's obviously dad all right
he knew where we were born he hated us
in 63 boom murders do you think dad is
capable of killing innocent people
i was being held captive
by the sparrows none of you noticed
of course we're just happier home safety
marcus they want him back unharmed we
don't have them then move on to problem
number two disappearing people wow
it was it was the wind who's the kid
that's it you're going back to euphoria
[Laughter]
shaving my nest you little puff don't
flatter yourself lyla i like my women a
little less likely to kill me in my
sleep we're learning so much about each
other
[Music]
how did he find her what the hell's
going on there's fighting
[Music]
oh yep just saw that one coming
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's a low blow five
i forgot how much i hate you you puny
little turd those feelings mutual lyla
really convenient how the nudity was
just covered up the whole time
[Laughter]
damn i thought this was netflix
that tit why is it you have two
briefcases one's yours nicked it from
the sparrows
and then we try mine
means you and i
gonna have to work together boom
oh but she'll be clothed dang it what do
you mean for you it's been a couple days
for me it has been over a decade i've
moved on thank you i've slept with many
many people
many
[Laughter]
the only relationship we have left is
the one with our child so you better not
screw that up
what am i supposed to do with him huh i
got important [ __ ] going on too i doubt
that be a dad
how does she know it's his though how
many as many people way
more than you poppy
why do you know that i don't think she
kept it
from it's her best friend she tells him
everything what if we just told the
truth
marcus is gone and maybe we're partially
responsible yeah that'll go over well
but throws a party i bet they throw
fantastic parties
she needs something to take her mind off
claire so we'll handle this thanks for
looking out for her
victor you're the best victor's really
the heart of this victor is the soul
what are they up to who
the umbrella academy i suppose that
means you are number one now marcus is
missing
i'm taking the rings
you had your chance once
didn't turn out too well that did it
tragic backstory
[Music]
oh that is messed up
ding son say that again
[Music]
[Music]
children
do you mind if i clean up do it quickly
get in my room mom if they bring marcus
back
so be it
marcus isn't coming back god took him
[Laughter]
god is in the basement and he called
marcus home
what did you say
does she need a checkup focus fay
we play this right
sparrow academy
is all ours this is why none of you
became number one exactly you don't
freaking listen got told exactly the
trail to follow the basement go to the
goddang basement get too power hungry
some of the sparrow academy feels like
the
not interesting characters in the matrix
sequels where the [ __ ] is marcus marcus
is uh
marcus uh marcus is safe
for now why would you say that see i
told you they have him
i warn marcus but no
he said we had to hear what you had to
say look he wasn't wrong okay we we want
to make things right with you by
kidnapping our brother no that's
just rumor them goddamn it
it's a it's a time traveling problem
we caused a paradox and that paradox is
swallowing things
lots of cows
and a dog
great job the briefcase for our brother
hotel obsidian four o'clock sharp or
we'll send him back in pieces
why are you capping we could go home
tonight
okay and for the first time in days i'm
feeling hope so please don't step on
that
just chill for a second
no more improvising okay
we do things together from now on got it
got it
i've had two angsty characters maybe
just try being less annoying oh my god
you're bad at this
just go somewhere for a few hours all
right it's a big city you are a terrible
dad
i'm so good at it
[Laughter]
i'm the best dad he's so funny this
season man funny last season too he's
way funnier this time
scuba class
scuba clows who are you up to
how are you
you're the drunk one aren't you no no
i'm klaus i'm the
spiritual one
pills bills and num nums i'm not hungry
come on i'm really not in the mood for
your [ __ ] today
hey what's up with you this season you
see him damn they like control him huh
yeah
knows that the
episode one or two
gonna move on
god damn sit
you see
what's up with that what is this it
doesn't concern you old man we say sign
you science
don't make me get christopher
damn
sparrow's little [ __ ]
what are you signing read it first you
can't you're a champ bridge
who are you people how did you get this
way
jesus christ
[Music]
hurry up douchebag starving telling the
robot to give you a bath he's not gonna
snitch on him
they need the umbrella's help
he originally does
you done messed up reggie
you raised the wrong kids
you don't raise the wrong kids
grace what the hell is going on down
here it's god
[Laughter]
sweet jesus
god
it's a bagel
perhaps it's the reincarnation of buddha
or brahma the creed yeah yeah whatever
don't be dumb no you can be dumb you're
allowed to be dumb grace is this what
took marcus
he went right up and touched it
praising man
the light of the lord is too much for
mere mortals
grace when did god get here when did
robots get religious that's what i want
to know so i will miss those pasty news
yeah well we could all stand to be shown
a little less skin these days
for you
yeah
he asked for a costume upgrade bring the
shorts back
i'm 99 sure that wouldn't work
oh i'm glad my pain amuses you you have
no idea it's like my
therapy if you're leading diego on his
payback for what happened in texas
you're pissing up the wrong ladder there
because that idiot may actually love you
the handler never did god five is such a
good character what's with the bottles
molotov cocktails what's with the music
none of your biz
yo collins neil diamond
are you making a mixtape
i met someone okay
and i thought you know maybe she'd like
some curated songs that just so happen
to express what's in my part oh my god
the boy is sprung i mean we've been here
for two days and the only time you sp
this is a mixtape for the enemy hey
sloan is not the enemy she's my love
oh [ __ ]
you guys had gravity sex
gravity sex
talking sandra bullock george clooney
never turn your back my boy
especially not to your children next
thing you know you've signed your life
away all your dreams have been quashed
all your plans run aground and the worst
of it
no one ever comes to visit anymore i
can't wait to be a dad
you ever been to a baskin robbins that's
me i feel like scoop after scoop after
scoop's been taken out of me brother
yeah i'm not following i'm it's kind of
confusing you know this
is a little weird
[Laughter]
do you want some ice cream
would that shut you up
yeah i do
oh i like seeing them get along yeah
unless he's gonna do something really
messed up right now i feel like he is
something's wrong with him he's got like
that
ice cream no
pillows
you don't want to take them oh no no no
no
that's against the rules i have to take
them every day against the rules break
the rules break the rules such as this
old necessary rehab trick
[Laughter]
but i must admit you're growing on me
oh this is fascinating oh man
i don't know how john sits in this chair
this chair so uncomfortable
like a goddamn champ
do you feel
left
yeah
i do good
you are
can we all get back to saving the world
now
that's so so strong what is this hotel
they can like do whatever they want hey
i really like the hair it's all
inclusive oh look at you trying number
ten
yeah it's a good choice
really
brings your face
oh my heart don't blow up the world
[Laughter]
[Music]
what did he say arivia
don't do it don't go down there
yes
yes
feed it
what is going on with that
robot i like it
[Laughter]
this is so stupid
power up [ __ ]
[Music]
all right where'd you guys go
i don't think this is where you wanted
to land i don't think you're in kansas
anymore
[Music]
why doesn't this family ever inform each
other where they're going
because then they work together well
what do we do when the sparrows get here
just follow our lead dance nice try you
don't take orders from you
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
damn these x-men ass costumes
damn luther you really got the hottest
one huh
i like her costume design sunglasses
raven girl yeah awesome design
killer it's on point
see having five on hand would really
come in handy
maybe we should try this again before i
lose my temper i got this
stupid
[Music]
this is why he needs
to keep him in check
[Music]
our boy yeah it's totally harlan it's
totally harlan
that you're about to die
let's see if it comes true
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
what the hell
is it him i think it is but he's clearly
clearly got some upgrades clearly worked
some some [ __ ] out since we last saw him
whoa
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god are they wiping out sparrow
academy
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
please confirm it confirm it she'll know
he'll know
oh my god
say it say it say it
harlan
knew it nipple chills
yeah i love being right
you're the only one who probably ever
guessed it
that was great
good that was awesome good man that's a
good one
proud of that one
proud of that
good one
slowly slowly getting back on track here
yes well not slowly but you know
let's do it
it's there
sometimes not most of the time yes
there's the sparrow the only thing is
like i just don't find the sparrow
academy that interesting and like to
have a
to have a cliffhanger oh what are you
doing why don't you take the headphones
off you know those are the microphone
the [ __ ] wrong they're not great
[Laughter]
oh god that's my only issue so far
really is like
they're all kind of one note and just
not that interesting and yeah you know
you have your cliffhanger
and then
and then you come back i'm like now
three episodes in and i'm like no you
guys are that
that interesting but everything else is
like really picking up and really much
more compelling there's a lot i'm really
liking about it um
i guess we're just going to talk about
it yeah screw it up
we'll have a little break but here we
are uh yeah i mean i like the
my my some of my favorite stuff is
actually uh all the things with hard
grapes and and klaus yeah that's so
tender and and so moving this whole
season seems to be about
one of the main themes is all about
parenting like all around you know you
got with um
diego and then of course like everything
with har graves
spot it right
with there parental struggles and
whatnot identity yeah well like klaus is
also looking you know like yeah the
whole search for the mothers and
everything so
yeah victor
victor as well yeah
that's true my identity is a really big
part of this whole journey
but i really really love the scenes with
klaus and and hard graves i i actually
really appreciate that flip on it
because
i think about like a little bit before
that scene occurred when when the other
two sparrow people broke in was like
sign this take your pills old man
a thought went off in my head of
there's something about this season
where the drama
seems to be a little bit intermittent
with
it feeling compelling
and then
a moment later that scene happened like
the second i had that thought and then
suddenly that scene happens and i'm like
oh well [ __ ] he just totally changed my
mind
right there because it's interesting to
take this approach where hargraves made
a dick move
and was like the umbrella academy are
failures i'm going to make the sparrow
academy instead
and then to watch how he's had terrible
experiences with them that have weakened
him and yeah just made him a little bit
more
just yeah his strength is just not there
and then now that weirdly creates this
unusual bond now between klaus and and
hargraves and maybe there's a way to
help each other that's not just plot
driven but also really character driven
so i think that's a really
really cool flipperoo to do
on it that i did not expect to see
happen so that was probably one of my
favorite elements of this one episode
yeah no i think it's interesting seeing
klaus now
uh bond with hargraves because in
previous seasons he's always been like
the the screw-up one and i don't know i
felt like the whole
thing with him trying to find his mom
felt kind of like out of nowhere because
he didn't really care the previous two
seasons so it makes sense that he's
establishing some sort of uh
parental bond with the character that
we're already familiar with that we
already know but an alternative version
of them to kind of maybe heal something
within him
as we go along um i also like seeing
lila and five bond because yeah start to
bond because you know he killed her
parents and then
i feel like they're gonna have something
to teach one another along their journey
of like resistance
and
seeing the the two of them with their
their powers and wherever they're going
is pretty cool uh i like seeing
uh what's his name number one happy just
there you go there we go i like seeing
one happy dang it he's love struck him
he's got the love bug in him
yeah
and uh yeah i think some of the problems
that
i had are similar to yours with the
sparrow academy kind of not really being
that interesting um the only thing that
really works for me in regards to the
sparrow academy is the things around
them like the thing that yeah that uh
that they're affecting like the stuff
with hard graves the stuff with
with a mom or uh the robot the
plot-driven mechanisms are the things
that are exactly that are good but the
character stuff is just not
that appealing and it's really a bummer
that's like that's it is it is a big
bummer to me they seem pretty one note i
think that's what they're very wonderful
they're super one note they have they
could have the opportunity to flesh them
out grant we're only three episodes in
but it doesn't feel like it's going that
direction because they're mainly
focusing on um the raven girl and yeah
ben
i don't know the other ones are kind of
just there because in some ways it's not
exactly a multiverse thing uh but it's a
timeline thing it's a timeline thing in
some ways they could be holding up a
mirror to each other and watching like
exploring who they are as characters and
but they just they just check in with
them and they're like all mustache
whirling villains
they literally have that uniform outfit
man
we have a little evil little bad
attitudes over time
marcus was the one only one who seemed
fleshed out
now he's not even here and he's dead
yeah i also think it's interesting how
they went from
being uniform to the the catalyst of
marcus dying and it seems like that's
the downfall for both iterations of
hargraves children is the death of one
of them kind of breaks them apart oh
yeah good good pool there yeah yeah and
i think that um
yeah we'll we'll see the the further
division of these characters and then it
seems like
the what what's the number five is that
um is that
luther's lady
sloan sloan yeah her name i think i
think she's gonna she's gonna join the
umbrella academy because she doesn't
seem
like she vibes with the other you know
she's like she's the only good one yeah
i'm like how did you survive so long if
all your your siblings are dicks like i
really like
i like the actors other than i'm not
digging what ben's doing but no no i
like i like the actors though and the
roles i think they all bring something
to the characters for sure it's really
just the the lackluster writing on them
but i really i really did um like i like
i like diego a lot i don't remember him
being this funny he was great last
season especially the stuff with him in
the uh the asylum i remember that stuff
was he really funny i don't remember him
being that funny he was super angsty in
the first season and they they punched
him up and made him funny in season two
but they've just continued that with
season three uh a character that's not
working for me on the umbrella side
academy on the umbrella side is uh
alison
he's a little too angsty
uh kind of on par with ben it's like
it's still it's stemming from a problem
that
it makes sense that she would have but
the way they went about it seems a
little strange and just how she's
reacting to the choice or how she's
reacting to the news of not having her
daughter feels a little weird to me but
maybe they'll resolve it in some sort of
way that feels
natural or satisfactory
i mean she's just i think
i don't know i get what they're doing
and but just because i get it doesn't
mean i'm enjoying what they're doing
like i understand she lost she doesn't
have her kid she's uh
she's feeling like that time anxiety in
a way
which is a real thing i learned about
recently and time anxiety
yeah like uh
i don't i mean i just learned about it
and it's something that i was like oh
[ __ ] i definitely have this where you're
constantly
i mean
i'm not talking like time in terms of
time travel but
it always feels like a race against the
clock
always in a rush and um
she's kind of feeling this you know
feeling this loss and now she's taking
it out here and just like how victor
says in this episode needs something to
focus on but is becoming hyper
aggressive and wants to reclaim it back
so feeling like the only way to do it is
through
hyper aggression
so i understand
i'm not
really
enjoying it myself
there are qualities to the drama in this
like i really feel like the drama in
season one and two
more season one took a little while for
me for it to get really compelling for
me but but season two especially like
that was very like just right away was
everything was so captivating
and then this one
it kind of falters here and there like i
like like we were saying with lila and
and five
seeing like the you know the misfit duo
these two who shouldn't work together
but they're going to i like that a lot
and
but you know when they start fighting at
first i'm like why are we doing this
there's no tension or stakes to this
this is just like it's not even that
good of a fight like why are we wasting
our time with this
like a lot of cuts why is she naked like
why does it need to be the same i just
didn't understand that
it's like sometimes sometimes i feel
like this and to me that moment kind of
summarizes some of my issues with
certain ways this season so far has been
executed
is sometimes it feels like they're
they're mainly setting out to be
entertaining and fun
but sometimes the drama seems to be kind
of lacking in a real focused way
and
so that scene kind of resembles that to
me is like let's just have a fight scene
and i'm like why yeah why don't we don't
need this fighting yeah it's it's it's
like uh
it's somewhere between like things that
make sense and that are interesting for
our characters in the plot but to get us
along in that journey we have to have a
lot of things for the sake of having
them they don't necessarily make the
most sense
sure like that fight scene
like the how they went about
uh dealing with the fact that they were
in the wrong timeline
um yeah just like a bunch of stuff
that's like kind of adding up and it's
not enough to detract for the overall
enjoyment of the show but it is
noticeable that these things are are
happening yeah i guess the feel the word
i'm looking for is it's not as
the so far this season like i enjoy i
really enjoyed the last episode and i
really enjoyed this episode
however it doesn't feel as gripping you
know what i mean like that's where
like before it was just like man oh like
i'm just eating it up and now i'm like
like no it's really good but it's still
there's something that i'm not quite
it's not quite
getting getting its hooks in my heart as
much as it as it did before
uh but i i am enjoying it i i feel like
it's getting better and it's gonna get
there yeah you know i i enjoy this
how they've been making victor
elevating victor to be more of
the
the natural leader because it always
seemed that was kind of the direction
with that character
of you know in season one
well she's gonna be outcast i know dead
naming is a terrible thing to do i'm
talking about fictional characters here
okay
so
um vanya in season one right
was um
uh yeah she's outcast but she was also
like the most powerful so they had to
repress her you know like the phoenix
character
and then uh in season two again like
they they made vanya always the threat
um but oh but but if they just gave her
the opportunity they'd see that this
person is really
uh has the best heart and is the most
powerful of them all yeah and then this
season now that
you know vanya's found his true identity
as victor
then now we're seeing how he's more of a
leader
more capable more
you know understanding and able to
handle situations better than like
everyone so there's something about the
coolness of having more of the collected
version of victor
and uh the aggression of five you put
them two together and they are like the
leaders yeah
and i i really
really appreciate
them a lot the most and i think what
they're doing with victors
cool and i like how they've been keeping
the conversation going about the
transition
like luther reacting is a little bit
kind of remember in the last episode i
was saying like i wish there was a bit
of a like how do i handle this because
this is a thing that people have to deal
with all the time in real life and so i
really liked luther being like what okay
did we like throw a party like would i
like how do we do this i want to like i
want to show i'm cool and i'm accepting
of this whatever they make it like they
get two in their heads and i think that
is that is a moment that i i was kind of
craving for
to happen with victor and they gave me
that through the through the eyes of
luther so i was really appreciative of
that
i am kind of i'm not quite grasping what
this hotel is though yeah it's like some
sort of like weird amalgamation of like
outcasts versus like some like a sense
of like um supernatural energy or or
something like super power people there
or i'm like what is going on in this
hotel because they just seem like they
can do whatever the hell they want
it's all-inclusive baby get as much
alcohol as you want
but it's
never mentioned in in previous seasons
though so i'm like how did this even
come about
it's interesting i don't know i hope we
learn more about it as the show goes on
maybe
be something of relevance
i
i do really enjoy
the
the i do i do think diego and i know
what is that little guy's name ashtray
ashtray from euphoria
he called him ten didn't he
i don't know i think he called him 10 in
the show but
no no it's like a simple name it was it
was like a real stanley or something it
was like something like it was like a
straightforward name um i forgot what it
was
either way the kid uh
i like their chemistry a lot i think
they have great chemistry oh yeah
they're a lot of fun and for you know a
show that kind of threw you into
you got a kid diego
and they didn't really do much to be
like hey let me try to bond with my kid
you know i didn't do any of that
they had to have a pairing where it just
felt like an instant chemistry
and i think they did an excellent job
pairing them up like granted this guy
has a he's like an athlete this kid and
he you know he's also been in you know
first two seasons of euphoria fantastic
in that show
and
you know like in here his character here
while you know still like the the
category of
rebellious young kid
like that's who he is for it but kind of
loose cannon but it's so much different
in euphoria he's like he's kind of like
scary yeah yeah
yeah he's a scary kitty like you like
even real even when i before i knew he
was a boxer but i would never mess with
this kid he's gonna kill me you know
right and and here he he gets the chance
to be like more light and funny
and uh i think their chemistry is
excellent i love their chemistry
together and uh i love how like he's
always like you're you're a terrible dad
like you have no logic
and diego's always like
i'm good at this he always thinks he's
doing a good job
no i think it's uh it is definitely fun
to watch them and i think that uh as the
show goes on
obviously we'll see them bond and kind
of like accept each other as father and
son and i'm curious to see what the
catalyst of that is and then how that
intertwines with diego and uh
and lila kind of falling back with one
another yeah and then becoming a lovely
little family you know of bad parenting
what's the
what's the mom's name you forget milo no
no the mom grace grace yeah
are you enjoying i can't tell if you're
enjoying that or not the the actual
thing i think it's funny i think it's
really hilarious
i'm enjoying it because it's like why is
a robot religious why is she like
humming and doing like chants and stuff
i was like what the heck is happening i
don't know i i'm making fun of it but
because i like it you know they are
trying to i actually kind of agree with
you on that like they are
it seems like they're trying to make it
feel like this this grandiose this is
grandiose malevolent thing but it's just
kind of like amusing
like oh no some evil amongst us but it
is just kind of
humorous in a way that
not like i don't find it as funny as you
but it is it is a little like
this isn't spooky or something but it is
just more like what's wrong with her
right it reminds me of um i guess the
it reminds me of an elephant an element
of a movie that you watch recently
everything ever all at once but i don't
want to get into that for people who
haven't seen that movie yeah but um
yeah i think it's really entertaining i
don't know why nobody seems to
acknowledge the fact of what's happening
in the basement outside of grace like
klaus knows about it the sparrow academy
or two of them know about it but like
they don't tell the others like klaus
has a cell phone right like you could
tell them something's going on does they
have a cell phone i'd imagine so they're
like in the present day but did they
pick up cell phones when they got back i
think it's just like
a common thing i mean
you would think they would you know
maybe he's working with hard graves on
it
but yeah it is kind of like why why'd
the sparrow academy decide to meet up
with him at the hotel when clearly
there's a much bigger issue at hand yeah
yeah why are they fighting
when they already got the information
about
about what's going on like with marcus
yeah grace literally told you like yeah
there's like a thing that killed my
brother yeah yeah
i don't know but i don't know spare
academies spirit academy is weird and
they got they got
synchronized costumes because they think
they're the x-men
they had the umbrella academy had super
nice costumes yeah but i don't theirs
are worse
i don't like except that one girl except
the raven girl her
her fits are on point i like i mess with
that
i don't make you feel strongly about it
no i don't
no they do they look like 90s they look
like early 2000s when they were like
let's make comic book movies yeah yeah
totally it's like something like early x
mondays
very brian singer yeah yeah except
without the bad stuff
maybe fine if the characters are more
interesting yeah
yeah but they're not doing much with
them
ben still sucks the hard graves come
harlan coming in
harlem coming in that was dope called
that [ __ ] they called it like episode
yeah knew it because yeah they they
teased at the end of the last season i
still wonder what's his deal though
cause what he has like some form of of
autism that we a lot of the traits they
play into or seem like it's autism a lot
a lot of the
very specific
like
ritualistic
almost ocd can't handle certain noises
um seems more powerful than vania
like off the bat that's what they seem
like they were alluding to in the last
season yeah that he could be but it
seems like he uh because we you kind of
have to think that he was like on a
mission to i think
how how much attention did he pay
towards
like when vania would return and stuff
like what year they were going to and
all that you know i don't know but we
have to think that what he got old
because like what we're we're now in
like 20
19 or 20 20. oh right now okay
i think the interesting thing about this
show is like they expect that you just
watch season two because like they'll
say some stuff like oh yeah like you
know i watched it like two years ago
like yeah yeah
for them it was like 20 days
since the beginning of season one even
though five looks like
incredibly old
for 20 days but um
yeah i think that
um watching them
go through time like that
and um
seeing what what vani has gone through
or what victor's gone through
that
we uh
we see
that
she hasn't they haven't had much time to
really explore their powers and harlan's
had 60 years to kind of like trone his
abilities good call good call
so yeah i think he's
killing it he's gonna be the mvp op i
mean you put freaking bonya and
oop
victor sorry everyone didn't mean that
you're getting canceled getting canceled
[ __ ]
i'm i'm the only one who's probably made
that mistake
who watches umbrella academy still wants
to be respectful
victor
apologies um
yeah but you put victor
and uh harlan together uh they're
unstoppable oh yeah
plus lilo
oh yeah and lila yeah yeah stop anything
yeah i mean harlan alone messed up
messed up all the sparrow academy right
almost almost like birth them to death
seemingly like they're dead
like uh i don't think they're dead spit
girl in um blood boy yeah
i did i love the makeup on him though he
looks cool it is great makeup on that
one it's gross but it's cool it's like
yeah it is fantastic makeup and it
doesn't look like a limits to the
performer the actor right so do you
think that
hargraves is do you think he's sick or
do you think they're giving him like
repression pills exactly
probably it seems like they're drugging
them up yeah to make them weak yeah yeah
i just wonder how they yeah like how do
they get to that point though because
you raised them so how did they get to
the point where he started to control
them
or they start to control him versus him
controlling them i mean they probably
wised up and realized we're more
powerful
yeah
who started that though five kind of put
him in his place when he was still
around what he died at the end of
episode one yeah and he was like sit
down
i mean the the sparrow academies
both the umbrella and sparrow
they have an ego problem
but the sparrow is is much more
they don't fight the biggest difference
between them is they don't fight for
hargraves approval
yeah they don't they don't seem to give
a [ __ ] about it it's true that it's all
about them and they're the [ __ ] and
hargraves is just a thing in their way
and they just use his money and [ __ ]
yeah you know so i i think that
because they don't have that feeling
because that's the number one thing
hargraves had over them
was
they were constantly fighting to get
approval
and that's that's kind of what unites
them like that brilliant scene in season
two when they're all at the table and
luther rips open the shirt
yeah and they're like yeah
yeah yeah see they're like oh man this
is great i really hope we get drama like
that in this season because right now
it's kind of like intermittent yeah
everyone's like inner conf that's the
thing is i think with season two they
establish like
great new starting points for each
character and where they're at and here
it's like
it doesn't feel that the aim does not
feel as strong with where our characters
are at
yeah what because you know what it's
it's the simple basics of writing of
just like
what's their inner conflict
and they have an external goal and then
who will they have to change into
by the time they achieve said goal right
and and hear them like it's kind of like
all
a little bit up in the air for a lot of
them like
it kind of feels more plot driven and
less
character driven and that's
that's when this show really shines to
me is when they make it
like when it's truly weaved into both
yeah i think the thing that
this season's missing at the previous
two seasons had is that
we established our group of main
characters and their history and there
is tension
uh stemmed from the time
that they spent apart so like there's a
lot of friction amongst the family
themselves and then in season two you
still have some of that friction plus
them being separated and having to come
back together but by the end of season
two they're all like uniform again and
they're the umbrella academy so
when you come into season three having
just come off the heels of that
there's no inner drama between the
family themselves so they have to create
an obstacle for these family to overcome
and i don't think it's as interesting as
them trying to
emotionally combat one another yeah and
it seems like it's kind of headed down
on another obvious path
of
by the end of the season they'll
probably have to all work together again
like yeah
and like okay yeah sure but
this is a stretch i kind of hope somehow
we get rid of this band and they somehow
bring the other bend back to life
uh that'd be nice yeah yeah cause
there's been ain't clicking this man
sucks
[Laughter]
bedding this is oh yeah
because yeah cause i like the i missed
the the ben klaus dynamic and there's
that was really fun
yeah but even like even like with klaus
too you know we as much as we there's
only so long we can watch like alcoholic
klaus uh you know that is still the
part of what made his character so
fascinating is is he's such a tortured
soul yeah and right now i just feel like
he's a funny guy yeah it's like he's got
the elephant it seems like they're
looking for things to like make them
more interesting but
like even with luther i really enjoy
luther he's so funny and he's so
enjoyable
but you know i've seen him like [ __ ]
pieing over
um allison two seasons now
now oh just a different girl doing that
you know i just find it over 20 days ago
yeah i got some new woman it
surprisingly just feels more yeah like
it's just setting out to be fun and
entertaining but not have that that
there's there's there is a lack of truly
gripping heft that's not quite
but i know how people are when they
watch their shows you know
they you know probably people who are
like
strongly disagree with us and like this
is the best yeah what are you talking
about yeah
sure if you feel that way that's your
opinion i mean you're wrong yeah
we're
i'm an influencer i'm here to influence
your opinion
in a different direction
no i'm just here to give my i give our
opinion and that's all we can do we're
here to be honest all right guys well
thank you for being here
i got to get air in the [ __ ] out of
here
yeah yeah we gotta try here
um thank you so much for being here
and uh hey let's do a pic
brian perry it's your shout out today
buddy i don't know anything about the
show that this is going on to so i hope
that for your sake you can fill me in
this is really a plea for you to come to
me with your best umbrella academy
knowledge because three seasons and i
can't catch up on all that other stuff
dude like so
if you can maybe make me some cliffs
notes or so you know what forget it
brian let's just hang out all right i
want to get to know you i want to talk
to you i want you to give me a massage i
haven't had a massage since before the
pandemic brian can you believe that
you
are i feel like you have a relaxing
calming energy this is what i get when i
see your name i'm like brian just that o
in your name brings it this extra sense
of sort of rounded calmness and i feel
like that's something i could use in my
life because i get anxious very easily
with all the things going on around here
especially with shows and things like
that that i don't know any details about
i'm like dude how am i going to keep my
head straight and it's you man it's you
who can help me do that
about other people and looking out for
other people especially when they're in
need or when they're ailing or suffering
or experiencing some kind of you know
real disruption physical or otherwise
mental maybe even but
dude i feel like that's not the case for
you you seem like you would be calm in
all situations you're the jelly to my
peanut butter brian perry and i hope
you're doing well so uh much love and
we'll catch you on the next
[Music]